asylum-seekers stranded on the North
Shore's of lesbos some have spent the
night here out in the open police can't
process them at the only refugee camp on
the island in Moria it's been blockaded
by angry Islanders who want it shut down
but maurya's occupants aren't happy to
be here either this was the latest of
many riots this year asylum processing
is slow and many have been living in
tents under the olive trees for a year
believe them doctor we didn't suffer
this is very difficult for
implementation if we not have a good
food it's a very good water we leave the
doctor this is very important hundreds
of maurya's asylum seekers recently
marched down to the port after recieving
misleading or mistaken messages that the
government was evacuating them to Athens
police had to turn them back this tense
situation is likely to become worse as
Turkey has opened its border and is
advising refugees on its soil to go to
Europe that's the reason why this 15
year old from Afghanistan is here he
says I have been in Turkey for two
months the smuggler called me in the
night and said the boat is ready get
ready to cross over
he said the border is open I could not
cross for two months because the border
was closed this video released by the
Turkish government suggests that the
Greek Coast Guard is no longer
conducting just search and rescue
missions but actively repelling
boatloads of migrants Greek Coast Guard
vessels can be seen driving perilously
close to small dinghies at another point
it appears shots are fired into the
water Greece has released video that
appears to show Turkish Coast Guard
vessels accompanying migrant boats to
Greek waters rather than holding them
back until now Greece and Turkey were
both working to keep undocumented
migrants out of Europe
Turkey's suspension of that arrangement
has led to the suspension of other
international norms Greece has declared
emergency measures it says it will stop
receiving asylum applications for one
month and in many cases it will turn
around undocumented migrants and send
them home without the usual reception
and
procedures so it will be as though these
people were never here Greece says these
new arrivals aren't individual
applicants but part of an organized
policy so international asylum law
doesn't apply to them as intended with
so many islands so close to the Turkish
mainland Greece has a difficult task
defending its maritime border but the
biggest losers in all this seemed to be
the asylum seekers jumps are Apollo's al
Jazeera lesbos